my name is Andrew cough I'm Ukrainian
writer Russian origin one of 10 million
ethnic Russians living in Ukraine when
the protest started it took me more than
two weeks to to grasp the whole hectic
movement of what was going on my done is
just getting together on the main square
paralyzing the central part of the city
or over town or village is a very
traditional and very old way of protests
in ukraine although the word comes from
Turkish and Persian languages may done
is just main square unfortunately I mean
the last one was violent but it was
violent because it had to deal not with
a real people of Ukraine mentality but
with people of collective Soviet
mentality we had a new political elite
completely from the east of the country
with the no knowledge of Ukrainian
history no knowledge of ukrainian
mentality traditional mentality and
that's why they were ready to use
violence
the main end they already almost cliche
example is the new police which defend
the the law and don't take bribes but
the main problem in Ukraine remains the
legal system because it is still corrupt
and we are talking about from my point
of view ninety ninety-five percent of
the judges should be replaced with some
new owners judges but I mean you cannot
find them immediately on the street in
the political sense i think ukraine
cannot be anything except democracy we
have so many different political parties
more than 200 political parties we have
every ukraine has his own opinion about
everything so I mean it's not a country
which can be ruled by one party and
controlled by one victory